it's not just you everyone seems to be
cold plunging or watching other people
do it
we're going to have cold plunger Josh
Cameron film the process
this is what is happening in his body
first the cold shock where the cold
might just take our breath away
as soon as you step into the water you
will activate your hyperventilation
and that is because you are not adapted
yet his body goes into fight or flight
mode from the cold shock every cell in
your body is going to be affected by
this stressor which is very potent for
you micro stress might feel painful in
the moment but it has long-term benefits
that will help your overall health by
increasing your metabolism and it will
help on your muscles on your fat storage
and it will help on your mental balance
the skin sends signals to the brain once
the body starts to get cold the
temperature and regulating Center sense
that wow this is an emergency it will
immediately increase nor adrenaline in
the body to activate our fight and
flight system we will have a huge
increase by 2.5 fold of no adrenaline
within a few minutes neurodrenaline acts
on what's called Brown fat a type of fat
tissue that keeps you warm by breaking
down glucose and fat molecules in the
body it not only Acts to Mr brownford it
also makes sure that our blood vessels
contract to our arms and legs so we can
keep the warm blood in the center of our
body because that's going to save our
vital organs activating this burn fat as
long-term benefits science is so that if
you can increase your metabolism by
activating the brown fat this could
actually be a way to prevent lifestyle
diseases such as type 2 diabetes
the longer time you stay in the water
the more heat you lose and then you will
have an activation of the muscles and
the first muscles that start to shiver
they're located in your chest and legs
pectoralis major which is the breast
muscle and also the femoralis which is
the big muscle on your thigh and when
you feel the muscles are shivering it's
time to actually get up you have ripped
all the benefits that you need the more
times you call plunge the more benefits
the body gets this includes an increase
in dopamine this dopamine increased from
cold emotion is just as high as nicotine
or cocaine let's go baby so this is
definitely the most natural high you
could get dopamine gives you drive and
motivation you'll have an increase of
2.5 full above Baseline of dopamine
that's not going to subside just
immediately as soon as you go up that
will last for hours afterwards an
increase in serotonin so after three
times after four times you also activate
your Vegas tone that would give you a
sense of mental balance because it
increases serotonin in the brain that is
not something you get from cold showers
for example you get that from submerging
into cold water and an increase in
oxytocin we have seen that from mice
studies they have an increase in
oxytocin and oxytocin is our love drug
natural drug in our brain that is
increased every time we fall in love or
we have sex so we eat chocolate touch
and stuff like that you don't
necessarily need to dunk your entire
body into cold water to reap the
benefits I found this very interesting
study from Canada from a Sciences group
they have calculated how much heat you
lose submerging your body into cold
water up to the neck versus how much
heat you lose from also dunking your
head submerging up to the neck you would
lose 11 of heat from the head but if you
also then do a head dug you will
increase that heat loss by 36 percent in
fact dunking your hand events can be
just as beneficial I found this very
interesting study in the bishop and they
work in very cold water with their hands
submerged many hours scientists found
they were cold adapted so the code
adaptation doesn't just come from
exposing your full body up to the neck
you can also expose parts of your body
and you will get a systemic effect
finally the after drop you will actually
be coated when you get up all your
muscles will start to shiver because
when you're in the water your body is
completely trying to shut out the cold
but when you get up the blood vessels
will dilate and the warm blood from your
core will flow out to your fingers and
your cold tissue and your muscles in
your core you have receptors which will
send then a signal to the brain telling
you oh now the blood has become much
colder that is a decrease in temperature
in your core and your muscles would then
start to shiver even more because now
you got colder that is completely normal
and just keep moving afterwards just
don't sit on your couch this principle
is called the superc principle and it's
named by a professor from Stanford
University called plunging is a practice
with a long history with the Egyptians
these first civilizations they built the
Seas and the rivers and thermal sources
around them in the gypsum times the
water was used for hygienic and clinical
purposes and with the Greeks Hippocrates
said that because of the imbalances that
we have the fluids in the body can get
stuck and that imbalance can be restored
going into cold water and warm water but
researching what happens in the body and
the potential benefits of the cold is
recent the Titanic actually sunk in
April the 15th in 1912 and there was a
big disaster but this is in history the
first time we really know how much time
the body can be in cold water before it
gets hypothermic from that on people
were thinking well cold water could
actually be really dangerous it didn't
really get any better when we jump right
on to World War II where Nazi
experiments were performed in the
concentration camps in daco to
investigate how long a human body could
be cooled before they died it has taken
decades before Sciences started again
investigating human physiology and cold
water in the 60s and 70s We Begin Again
to see studies where we can see what
happens when you put people into cold
water cold punching weekly can have many
long-term benefits another long-term
benefits of going into the cold water is
the increase in metabolism just by 11
minutes per week divided up two to three
days you will have an increase in
thermogenesis in the body so you will
get warmer you'll get an increased
insulin sensitivity and you will have a
better glucose balance meaning that you
would easier get rid of the glucose in
your bloodstream when you are adapted to
cold water the same study by Dr Dr
soberg and her colleagues suggest adding
warmth we also saw that going into a
sauna 57 minutes divided on two to three
days 10 to 15 minutes at a time you can
also increase your metabolism and you
will lower your core temperature which
is a good thing because then you have a
higher threshold for getting hypothermic
as well
the long-term benefits of cold plunging
seems to be that you will have a better
temperature regulation in your body you
will become a warmer person physically
apparently also emotionally that could
explain the culture that is also in the
winter swimming clubs that people get
this the Gratitude because they have
maybe this large increase in oxytocin I
think it explains why we see that kind
of friendly atmosphere there